Um, okay. We're going to launch here.
So, my [clears throat] name is Frank
Coyle. Um, I'm I'm an educator. I'm
teaching at Berkeley now. I've been
doing this uh computer science stuff for
oh, 30 35 years. And um I'm and right
now it's kind of a critical time for uh
the poor computer science students. They
used to be the used to be the only game
in town. Degree was a guaranteed job and
now thanks to AI it's not. But then
again 5,000 people are here. So AI and
and agents are u seem to be the way to
go. So the question is how do we
leverage this new universe that we are
moving quickly into? And so I want to
talk about how agents and ontologies big
word fit together. But before you before
I do that, I wanted to um I wanted to
give you my uh my educational
philosophy.
And this comes from someone called
Sister Karita Kent. And it was made
popular by John Cage who is a uh an
avanguard musician.
And
you got to think about this a little
bit. Nothing is a mistake. There is no
win. There's no fail. There's only make.
And more and more today, that's what's
important. Get down and make stuff. And
that's how you're going to learn. Not by
necessarily reading. I'm also a big fan
of writing. My early career was in
neuroscience. I'm kind of coming back
into it now that Agent AI is bringing uh
kind of cognitive science back. But
engage your senses. Get a notebook, get
a pen, a pencil, draw pictures, write
stuff down. Just don't type because when
you type, when you're typing, your brain
is thinking about the letters on the
keyboard. When you're writing in a book,
your whole brain your your whole s all
all your sensory systems are engaged and
you're going to learn faster that way.
Okay, on to our talk.
agents and ontology. So there are two
lineages here and I want to talk about
both give you a little philosophical
background. Um agents when did we start
talking about agents? It well goes goes
back to the early initial days of AI.
People like John McCarthy
uh uh uh Selfridge, Marvin Minsky,
Society of Mind, people started thinking
about the fact that this new computing
technology was going to lead us into
some kind of artificial intelligence,
which is a term that came in 1956 when
all these characters got together and
tried to figure out where the future was
going. Okay. and the concept of an agent
finally evolved things that perceive and
decide and then act and that's what
we're seeing now. Now what about
ontologies? Well, it turns out
ontologies are not that new. Okay, it
was actually Aristotle who first came up
with the concept of we need a philosophy
of of being like woo kind of heavy um
but came up with categories of being and
this kind of relates to what people are
doing now with graph databases and
knowledge representation and there are a
couple of other people who kind of
formalized it uh vanquin was a
philosopher and then this guy Gruber
1993 and I think this captures is what
knowledge and uh
graph technology really represents. It
is a a formal specification of a shared
conceptualization and that's what we
want to give to our agents. We want to
give them our concept our
conceptualization of the universe, our
universe, our domains. Okay. And now
what's happening is you're getting the
convergence of something that is
probabilistic,
the agents, the LLMs with the the more
formal representations that you have
with ontologies. And so this term is now
being used. You hearing this a lot,
neuro symbolic AI. Sounds pretty fancy,
but it's really neural networks tied
into
symbolic AI, which rule-based systems
come under that category. Um, as do the
knowledge graphs that we're that we're
assembling. And so
what I like to argue is that neuros
symbolic AI sort of represents a way to
keep the LLM on its guard rails because
LLMs are by nature probabilistic.
People worry about hallucinations, but
that's the feature. That's actually a
feature of large language models. It's
who we are. We hallucinate in a way. We
imagine things that may not exist and
then we turn them into reality. And
that's what large language models do in
in a way. Okay. So,
let's just quickly overview what
ontologies are. It's not they're not
complicated. They're basically our
representation of entities and their
relationships to other entities. And
these entities have properties. And this
whole concept of graph databases
arose when people began to realize that
relational databases
sticking data into tables was too
restrictive. You wanted to add something
new to a relational database or you had
to add a new column. Man then you have
to redo the whole structure. With a with
a graph database you can just attach
another item. You can just attach a
property. you can attach a relationship.
Okay, so the question often arises,
okay, I I get it. I need to have an
ontology
to represent in a formal way what my
organization is doing. How do I do it?
Okay, there are a couple of ways you can
approach it. Can have a top- down
approach or a bottom up approach. Top
down approach is you get the experts
together and they sit down and analyze
the domain, come up with the entities.
What do we have? We have purchase
orders. We have customers. We have
customer representatives. And we're
going to structure them. They have
properties. These are the relationships.
Okay, that's one way. And this models
what we were doing back in the 80s when
I was involved in expert systems.
Everybody thought expert systems was the
way to do AI. Symbolic AI was the way to
go. Companies rose, millions of dollars
were spent. uh the uh the Japanese
created this uh future world project in
the late 80s people in America my my son
was taking Japanese in school because of
these expert systems and but they
couldn't scale they couldn't scale and
then we went into a kind of AI winter
where did neural networks came come from
neural networks were put out there in
the 60s but they couldn't scale because
we didn't happen to have Nvidia who was
off making GPUs to make make reality of
the of the video games fantastic and
then someone said let's turn these
things over to the neural networks and
of course that's kind of why we're here
now. So
the other way you can that that people
are adding to or creating ontologies is
is from the bottom up. For example,
customer
reactions. What are the things the
customers are involved in? Hey, the
these entities, these relationships,
let's add this to our ontology. Let's
let's add this information to the graph.
Now, as as a help,
it's helpful to be aware that there are
existing
taxonomies that people have been working
on for the last 15 to 20 years. Things
like schema.org, org which has a whole
set of terms and relationships. So you
don't have to reinvent the wheel. In
fact, you it's to your advantage to use
some of these ontologies. Th friend of a
friend for modeling social networks, the
Dublin core, which was an early an early
attempt to come up with terms for
describing
uh research papers and books and so
forth. So there's a whole series of
things. In fact, Wikipedia is based on
an ontology called DBPedia. So when you
do a search on Wikipedia, it's looking
things up in its giant graph database.
So this stuff has been out there
underlying a lot of what we already do.
So take advantage of these things that
already exist.
Okay. Now, what do you do when you build
your ontology? Okay. So what? I know
what these entities are. I know what
their relationships are. They have
properties. How can I do anything with
them? Well, there are other augmenting
technologies, auxiliary technologies,
things that we call things like RDFS,
which is a technology, and owl, which
I'll talk more about. So, these have
these kind of sit over to the side of
your graph. So, I'm not going to talk
about I mean, ontology is a big word and
it's often confusing and used in many
ways, but think you have a graph data
structure, okay? and you have the
entities and relationships but you want
to apply some control over them or you
want to be able to make inference over
them. So for example there is uh some
terms in this technology called RDFS
domain and range. So if I say
teaches has a domain of teacher that
means if I say Bob teaches scooter in my
text I can infer that Bob is a teacher
and if I say all teachers are persons
then this statement lets me know if I
say Bob teaches scooter now I know Bob
is a person Bob is a teacher. What about
scooter? If I say teaches has a range of
student that means a the right side of
the verb then scooter is a student and
now I have this extra information into
my system.
Owl also has a series of
of of properties that allow you to make
some inferences. So a transitive
property transitive property says if Sue
is an ancestor like ancestor is a
transitive property. If Sue is an
ancestor of Mary and Mary is an ancestor
of Anne, then Sue is an ancestor of
Anne. Okay, this was not initially into
my graph system, but with applying these
functional properties, I can then add
and augment the system with this extra
data. So that's very useful. Then
there's some properties called
functional properties, which means only
one. So has father is a functional
property. You can only have one father.
You can only have one mother. That is a
functional property. Okay. So that's
that can serve as a constraint. So when
if you say Bob is my Bob is Jim's
father, BB is Jim's father. Well,
the inference here is that Bob and BB
are two ways of representing the same
individual because that is a functional
property. You can only have one. So
these derivations and constraints don't
sit in the graph. They sit sort of on
the side and they can help as we're
going to see I'm going to propose when
we deal with agents how they can they
can help us out. So what about agents?
Everybody's talking about agents now and
everybody's talking about loops, loops,
loops, loops everywhere. Loops have been
around for a long time. Back in the 60s,
people were debating who has the best
programming language, forran or cobalt.
No, mine is better. No, mine is better.
Oh, you don't know anything. You don't
know what you're talking about.
Beam and Jacobini 1966 came out and said
okay there is no real difference in
programming languages if they have three
aspects
sequence I can put statement A statement
B statement C fine I have conditionals I
can have if then and the last piece I
have a loop if I have a loop if I have
iteration if I take these three things
the the language is what's called
touring complete can do any can compute
anything that a
can be computed by computational devices
from the work of Alan Turing. Okay. And
now we're seeing this in aentic AI
agents are now have loops. Loops give us
the last piece in the equation of giving
us a technology that is capable of
doing anything that computational
devices can do.
The danger though of loops is that they
can break. If you're if you're a
programmer, you know you've all go in an
infinite loop.
Not good. Loops can drift. As agents
start talking to each other, things get
off go off off the rails and loops can
cost you money. Token counts crank up as
the loops continue. So you don't you
need to be careful. Okay, but in a way
we are revisiting some of the early
stuff with symbolic AI. I would argue
we're going back to the world of expert
systems
which is the symbolic part of the whole
thing. So I want to show you a little
example using clawed agent. So little
code here. Don't get scared. But I know
nobody does Python anymore, but you got
to look at what the agent's giving you
and you gotta you got to move in and and
manipulate it. So here's a here's a loop
while true classic Python loop. Okay.
And so we have a client. So we're
actually so the first little chunk here
that you see RSP the response. This is
just some code where we have a model and
we have uh we have a prompt that's part
of part of the messages and we have a
tool
and we're we're asking the LLM to
solve this problem using a tool. Now
here's the here's the catch. LLMs can't
do anything. All they can do is give us
the next word with a high probability.
Amazingly, we can now have these
conversations with it, but they can't do
anything. But we can give it a tool and
we can give it what we want and say,
"How do you think this tool can help us
get what we want?" And then the LLM will
set up the parameters
and come back to us and say, "Okay,
here's my response. I can't execute this
tool, but I know what the input
parameters are. I know what your context
is. I know what your prompt is. So, here
is the call that you need to make of the
tool because I can't do it. I'm the LLM.
I'm just locked in this box. Okay. So,
the second B the second chunk is
stop reason. So, stop reason means the
LLM has stopped for some reason. The the
reason here is that it can't do
anything. And if the reason is tool use,
ah now it's time let's go execute that
tool. So that second line get tool. It
takes the response which is formulating
the the parameters and triggering the
action. Okay. Now there's stuff in red
here. This is where I think the LLMs and
other uh I'm sorry not LLMs, the
ontologies and stuff can come in. So
if you look down there
after the the tool is called it said
tool runs this is where ontologies could
come in. The tool's going to give us
information. We put the information in a
form that our our our validator can use
and think about the validator as
operating with this these ontologies
about our domain then we can
make some sense of whether the response
of the LLM is reasonable. So this is the
loop. Call a tool, check the stop
reason. If it's a reasonable result,
then let's go with it. If it's not
reasonable, go back to the LLM, say,
"Oh, this is this is not working or get
a human in the loop." But the idea is
to surround the input with checks. Now,
I've got this something that you that
you should be at least taking a look at
if you're doing some of this coding is
something called pyantic. Pyantic is a
way to specify
the types of what you want the types of
the parameters to be. Those of you who
who do know Python know Python is a
unstructured type language. So you can
have a variable x= 20 x equals hello no
problem. There's no typing. Pyantic adds
typing to that. So you want to check
your types with pyantic and then check
your results with the ontology.
So, Panic at the door, ontology at the
ledger, and pure agents. By the way,
your agents should try to have no side
effects.
That helps the whole logic. Meaning,
they're not running off doing something
that they're they're changing they're
changing things in the database. Not
yet. You want to run them through the
ontology first and make sure that works.
Okay. I only got I've got another just a
short time. I'm going to try to show you
some of the things that um that you can
some logical constructs from from you
call owl the uh
the web object language for for objects.
So you have these functional properties
disjoint properties. I'll just put these
you can look at the slides but
essentially the errors it can catch look
over in the the right hand column. a
second refund on the same order is a is
is a problem. Ontologies could catch it.
Whereas it's ver it's very tricky to do
that in in English. A payout sent to the
support desk instead of the buyer. Okay.
You can catch that with an owl disjoint
property where customer and support rep
are two separate entities. Okay. Uh one
of may a madeup value like probably
shipped. you can specify
you must have certain kinds of value.
So, uh the status paid, shipped or
refunded, nothing else. And when you're
in the pure text world, this can get
this can get funky because the the LLMs
are again probabilistic and um
return some crazy stuff. Okay. Uh so
really what the point I want to make
here is use these re you can have a
reasoner built ontology to check keep
the LLM on track have guardrails to keep
it honest okay and for the guardrails
I'm referring to these concepts rel
these support technologies with RDFS and
owl
and
my my bottom line is Nothing is a
mistake. There's no win, no fail. Only
make. Okay. Feel free to reach out to
me. Coyle at Berkeley. I've got a I've
got a I've got a little website
co-supreme.ai. I'm a big fan of if
you're John Cold Train has a has a some
jazz called uh called Love Supreme. So,
I've named my site code supreme. And if
you go there, I got some music and it's
all good. Okay. Thanks very much. It's
20 minutes. [applause]
>> [music]